de liderar el estado a enfrentarse a los
tribunales 14 meses después de que la
obligaron a dejar el poder aún san suu
syi fue declarada culpable
el último cargo más de 11 kilos de oro y
600 mil dólares que presuntamente aceptó
como soborno de un colega el ex primer
ministro de la ciudad de rangún una
sentencia de prisión de cinco años que
se suma a las otras dos condenas que
recibió hace solo unos meses por burlar
las reglas de covite e importar walkie
talkies lo que supone que la ascendencia
suman 11 años hasta el momento los
juicios han sido rechazados por algunos
sectores de la comunidad internacional y
la propia sushi calificó previamente la
acusación de absurda
pero la junta militar que le quitó el
poder el año pasado dice que el juicio
está a cargo de un poder judicial
independiente y está permitiendo que la
mujer de 76 años cumpla su condena bajo
arresto domiciliario en un lugar no
revelado
susi pasó 15 años bajo arresto
domiciliario por liderar una lucha no
violenta por la democracia por la que
ganó el premio nobel de la paz en 1991
en total los 18 cargos en su contra
conllevan a una pena de cárcel máxima
combinada de casi 190 años